ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูนิคสวัสดีครับครูหญิง
สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนตายขาสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนวันนี้วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
ศุกร์ครับ
วันนี้วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 13 ครับค่ะเดือน
อะไรคะเดือนพฤษภาคมครับ
ปีพตอะไรคะดีพ.ต.ต.
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครูนิตอน
นี้ที่อเมริกาเวลา
อา
08:03 นตอนเช้าครับเป็นผู้เวลาเช้าๆชาย
แล้วที่
ผู้หญิงตอนนี้กี่โมงครับตอนนี้ที่ไทยนะคะ
ที่กรุงเทพฯค่ะ 20:00 น 3 นาทีค่ะ
โอเคเป็นเป็นตอนใจคืนนอนเหอะชายผู้หญิง
กำลังจะนอนแล้วนะคะแต่คุณนึกเนี่ยเพิ่ง
ตื่นอ่ะอย่าเพิ่งตื่นครับหัวแปลกๆตอนนี้
ไม่เป็นไรนะคะ
คุณผู้หญิงสบายดีไหมสบายดีค่ะครูนิคก็คะ
สบายดีนะคะดีสบายดีครับชายสบายดีแล้วหลัง
จากดื่มกาแฟอ๋อแปลว่าครูนิคแน่นอนตื่นดี
ขึ้นมาต้องดื่มกาแฟ
ใช่ๆครับคุณนิคชอบดื่มกาแฟคุณนิดต้องดื่ม
กาแฟหลังจากตื่นขึ้นมาไม่งั้น
สมองมันไม่ทำงานงั้นคุณก็จะแบบสวัสดีครับ
คุณ
น้องคุณนี้ก็มีกาแฟก็แบบอ๊อดทำงานได้ดี
ถ่ายขวัญบางคนใช่ไหมคะบางทีทำงานไปนานๆ
มันก็จะรู้สึกแบบเหนื่อย
ใช่ๆครับอะไรก็ต้องแบบชาร์จพลังใช่ไหม
ชาร์จแบตเตอรี่เหมือนครูนิคดื่มกาแฟก็
เหมือนชาร์จแบตเตอรี่ใช่ใช่ครับๆก็พอดื่ม
กาแฟก็จะรู้สึกมีพลังและอยากทำอะไรก็ก็ทำ
ได้เลยทำงานไปข้างนอกเจอเพื่อนไปเที่ยว
ที่ไหนก็ได้ครับโหใช่คู่นี้คุณนี้พูดถึง
ไปเที่ยวไปเที่ยวก็เหมือนชาร์จแบตเตอรี่
นะคะใช่ใช่ครับใช่ทำเป็นการครับก็ใช่คน
นี้ก็เป็นเหมือนกันเวลาถ้าทำงานเยอะๆจะ
ต้องมีเวลาที่หยุดออกไปเที่ยวหรือไปที่
อื่นเพื่อชาร์จพลังให้กลับมาทำงานได้แล้ว
จะได้กลับมาทำงานแล้วก็แบบเย็นพร้อมแล้ว
พร้อมเจอพร้อมเจองานของเจอชีวิตจริงอีก
อะไรเหงาน้องแต่ว่าแบบถ้าเราจะไปเที่ยว
ใช่ไหมเราก็ต้องคิดว่าพ่อเราจะทำยังไงเรา
ก็ต้องวางแผนใช่ไหมคะถ้าเราจะไปเที่ยว
ครับใช่ชาติดีก็หน้าแรกเลยเนาะก็ต้องน่า
จะต้องเก็บเงินก่อนใช่ไหมคะคุณอายุต้อง
เกิด
ต้องทำไม่มีเงินถ้าไม่มีเงินไปเที่ยวไม่
ได้ไม่ได้และก็อย่างอันนี้ใช่ไหมเขาก็
ต้องมีกระปุกนะคะแล้วก็เอาเงินใส่ลงไปใช่
ไหมเก็บเงินถ้าคิดจะไปเที่ยวก็ต้องเก็บ
เงินก่อน
ใช่ๆเก็บเงินก่อนข่าวก็
เก็บเยอะเก็บน้อยแล้วแต่ว่าเราจะไปที่ไหน
เนาะใช่ค่ะถ้าเราจะไปที่เอาหยังไปยุโรป
อย่างเงี้ยมันไกลน้องแพงก็อาจจะต้องเก็บ
เงินเยอะแต่ถ้าไปแบบใกล้ๆก็อาจจะไม่ต้อง
เก็บเงินเยอะเท่ากับไปยุโรปใช่เยอะเหมือน
ถ้าเราจากกรุงเทพไปเชียงใหม่และก็เก็บ
เงินน้อยกว่าจากกรุงเทพไปเอ่อฝรั่งเศส
ทรายว่าถ้าจัดกรุงเทพไปฝรั่งเศสก็อาจจะ
เก็บเงินน้อยกว่ากรุงเทพฯไปอเมริกาไหมถ้า
จะนอนก็น้อยกว่าคิดว่าน้อยกว่าเพราะว่า
ค่าตั๋วเครื่องบิน
ถูกกว่าถ้าไปฝรั่งเศสนะจากคือเวลาเราไป
เราต้องนั่งเครื่องบินนะคะเครื่องบินจาก
กรุงเทพไปอเมริกาเนี่ยแพงกว่ากรุงเทพฯไป
ฝรั่งเศส
ใช่ๆแล้วพอเก็บเงินได้แล้วเนี่ยนะคะต่อไป
เราก็ต้องคิดว่า
เราจะไปเที่ยวที่ไหนดี
ครับ
ใช่ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงชอบที่ไหนเป็นพิเศษชอบ
ไปอาเลเซียชอบไปยุโรปหรือชอบไปที่ไหน
ถวิลผู้หญิงเคยไปยุโรปแค่หนึ่งครั้ง
ครับก็คือเคยเคยเอเชีย
เอเชียเอเชียเคยไปแค่ประเทศลาวเองอ่ะครู
นี้ขอ
โอเคแต่ถ้าคุณเล็กยังไม่เคยไปประเทศลาว
อย่างไปแต่คูนิคิดว่าออยอยู่ใกล้ๆประเทศ
ไทยไปเมื่อไหร่ก็ได้แล้วเป็นไงคะตอนนี้
เอาคนดีไม่ใกล้แล้วก็อยู่ที่อเมริกาก็เลย
อยากไปผู้หญิงเนี่ยอยากไปญี่ปุ่นนะคะอยาก
ไปประเทศญี่ปุ่นมากๆก็อาจจะต้องเก็บเงิน
มากกว่าไปประเทศลาวหน่อย
เอ่อเออใช่ๆๆโทรศัพท์ประเทศลาวอย่างไปคิด
ว่าเดี๋ยวต้องตอนนี้ต้องเก็บเงินเยอะและ
เขาว่าฮ่าๆจากอเมริกาไปเอเชียไกลแล้วนั้น
ยิ่งนานใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าถ้าครูนิคกลับมา
ประเทศไทยแล้วมีเวลาก็ค่อยไปเที่ยวที่
ประเทศลาวๆใช่ข้างหน้าๆๆก็เก็บเงินได้
แล้วเลือกได้แล้วใช่ไหมคะว่าเราจะไป
เที่ยวที่ไหนเรารู้แล้วว่าเราจะไปที่ไหน
น้องครับต่อไปเราก็ต้องเลือกวันนะคะว่า
เราจะไปเที่ยวเมื่อไหร่
ว่าตอนนี้ก็เดือนที่ 5 แล้วเนาะข่าว
ถ้าอย่างแบบที่อเมริกาเนี่ยคนอเมริกาเขา
จะไปเที่ยวช่วงเดือนไหนหรอคะคุณแต่
จริงๆแล้วคนที่นี่เขาจะบ้านแล้วแต่อากาศ
นะแล้วแต่แต่ที่เขาอยู่ด้วยเหมือน
ที่รักที่คุณนิดอยู่เนี่ยมันจะรัฐ
วิสคอนซินเนี่ยคนจะชอบไปเที่ยวไปในรัฐ
อื่นช่วงฤดูหนาว
ครับฤดูหนาวนี่เดือน
ที่นี่ดูหนัง
ประมาณจริงๆแล้วที่นี่ฤดูหนาวจะเริ่ม
ธันวาคมอ่อนเดือนธันวาคมให้หลายๆที่ไทยนะ
คนไทยก็จะเริ่มไปเที่ยวเนี่ยเดือนธันวาคม
เหมือนกัน
หายแต่คนที่นี่เนี่ยที่รัฐที่คุณนิคอยู่
เนี่ยเขาไปเดือนธันวาคมเพราะเขาหนีหนาว
แต่คนไทยไม่ใช่นะคนไทยเนี่ยไปหาว่าเอ๊ย
ญี่ปุ่นหนาวเกาหลีปีนี้หนาวยุโรปหนาวแล้ว
ก็ไปหาหนาวอันนี้ไม่ใช่อันนี้ตี๋บอกว่า
ที่นี่หนาวมากหนีหนาวเพราะว่าอากาศมัน
หนาวจริงๆคุยหญิงที่นี่ถ้าฤดูหนาวเนี่ย
ติดลบ 15 องศา
ติดลบ 20 องศาเลยนะ
เหอๆ
ใช่เขาก็เลยไม่อยู่ละที่นี่มันหนาวมากก็
จะไปเที่ยวเขาก็จะไปเที่ยวที่รักที่มี
อากาศดีกว่าเอ่อก็ไปฟอริด้ายกตัวอย่าง
โซลิด้าเขาจะอากาศอุ่นอากาศร้อนค่ะครับ
เพราะว่าไปถึงจะเป็นฤดูหนาวที่ฟอริด้าแต่
ว่าอากาศก็จะ
ประมาณ 25 ค่าจอไม่ไม่ไม่ได้ติดขอจบใช่
ไหมคะฟอริด้าแล้วประมาณติดลบใช่ครับเพราะ
คู่นี้ก็จะไปฟอริด้า
ธันวาคมเหมือนกันขึ้นเพราะว่าคุณมีกันหนี
หนาวที่หนาวใช่เราที่รัฐของคุณนิคเนี่ย
ฤดูหนาวมันยาวมันได้กี่เดือนคะคุณประมาณ
สี่เดือนนะฮะผู้เดือนอะไรบ้างคะเนี่ย
เดือนก็
คม
มกราคมเราก็กุมภาพันธ์
มีนาคม
ครับใช่บางครั้งอ่ะก็จะยาวไปถึงเมษายน
ด้วยครับก็แล้ว
คนก็จะดี
มีอีกหนาวใช่ส้มตรงข้ามกับคนไทยนะคะคนถ้า
ไปเดี๋ยวจะไปเที่ยวคือไปหาอุ้ยที่ไหนหนาว
ที่ไหนหนาว
ที่ไหนหนาวที่ไหนมีหิมะ
ทรายทำไมคนไทยถึงไปเที่ยวช่วงเดือนแบบ
ธันวาคมหรือเดือนมกราคมเพราะว่าถ้าใน
ประเทศไทยอย่างเชียงใหม่เชียงใหม่ก็หนาว
นะคะหรือว่าแบบญี่ปุ่นเกาหลียุโรปเนี่ย
หนาวมันก็จะไปเที่ยวประมาณนั้นๆคุณนี้คิด
ว่าเวลาคนอยากไปเที่ยวหนึ่งเขาอยากไปที่
นี่อากาศมันไม่เหมือนที่เขาอยู่
อุ้ยพูดนี้คิดว่าแบบนั้นอ่าก็เหมือนกัน
น้องเวลาสมมติถ้าครูหญิงคิดอยากจะไปต่าง
ประเทศแล้วก็ไปตอนฤดูร้อนก็คิดนะโอ๋
ประเทศไทยก็ร้อนเราไปเที่ยวก็ร้อนก็จะไป
ทำไมเข้าไปความไวก็จะดีอย่างนึงก็คือมี
เสื้อผ้านิดหน่อยฮือ
ๆแต่ครับพบคนนี้คุณนี้คิดว่า
ถ้าเกิดเราไปที่อากาศมันเหมือนกันกับที่
เราอยู่คนนิเทศว่ามัน
สำหรับคุณนิดมันเสียเวลานิดหน่อยเพราะของ
EM เราก็ไม่ต้องนั่งเครื่องเพื่อไปกิน
ของกินที่ตรงนั้นเพราะอากาศมันเหมือนกัน
หากินแถวๆประเทศเราก็ได้เหมือนเราไม่ได้
ไปเที่ยวใช่ไหมคะเหมือนเราไม่ได้ไป
เปลี่ยนไปเปลี่ยนอากาศไปเปลี่ยนความรู้
สึกก็แบบก็ร้อนอ่ะที่บ้านฉันก็ร้อนครับ
ชายก็คุณนิดจำได้ว่าตอนที่คุณนิดเนี่ยไป
ออสเตรเลียตอนแรกก็ไปที่โอ้นี่แล้วมัน
เป็นฤดูร้อนอากาศก็ร้อนนะประมาณ 40 องศา
หารถเหมือนที่ไทยเลยนะคะใช่ร้อนร้อนมาก
แล้วคุณนิคไปที่ Sydney เนี่ยคนไทยก็อยู่
เยอะค่ะ
ก็คือนี้ไปถึงแม่มากไปถึงซิดนีย์หิวข้าว
จะออกไปหาของกินคุณนิคเดินไปไหนก็ได้ยิน
เสียงคนไทยแล้วมันก็มีตึกสูงคุณนิคคิดว่า
เหมือนเดินอยู่แถวสาทรอ่ะ
ไม่ๆๆเหมือนอยู่ต่างประเทศอ่ะ
อยู่ประเทศไทยเหมือนอยู่กรุงเทพฯแบบนี้
ตึกเยอะๆแล้วก็มีฝรั่งอยู่เยอะมีคนต่าง
ชาติแล้วก็ได้ยินเสียงคนไทยมีร้านอาหาร
ไทยเยอะเหมือนกันคุณนี้ก็ยไปสมัครทำไม
ไม่นั้นเนาะเวลาถ้าแบบเราคิดจะไปเที่ยว
อย่างนี้ค่ะแล้วเราแบบเลือกได้แล้วเราจะ
ไปไหนสมัยเลือกวันได้แล้วอ่ะเราก็ต้องคิด
นะว่าเราจะไปเที่ยวที่ไหน
ใช่ใช่เปิดผับเลือกที่เที่ยวอะว่าเออถ้า
เราไปแล้วเราจะรู้สึกว่าเราได้เที่ยวรู้
สึกเหมือนได้เห็นอะไรที่มันแบบใหม่ๆๆ
ที่มันไม่เหมือนจากที่เราเคยเห็นน่ะ
ก็ดีนะคะเพราะว่าแบบอย่างเวลาถ้าผู้หญิง
ไปเที่ยวปกติก็จะวางแผนนะคะว่าแบบออกไป
กี่วัน
แล้วก็ไปเที่ยวที่ไหนบ้างทำไมวันที่ไปถึง
วันแรก
จะไปดูอะไรจะไปเที่ยวที่ไหนอาจจะกินอะไร
อะไรมันจะหาหาร้านร้านอาหารไปที่นี้คำไหม
ถ้ำธรรมครับคุณนี้ก็จะหาดูว่าไปที่ไหนมี
อะไรน่าสนใจให้ดูครับแล้วก็อาหารของกิน
คุณนี้ก็จะดูว่าอะไรที่คุณนิคไม่เคยกิน
อะไรใช่อะไรที่ไม่เคยกินอะไรที่มันดีกว่า
ที่ที่คุณนี้เคยอยู่เกี่ยวกับของกลิ่น
Rose แปลว่าเวลาที่ครูนี้จะไปเที่ยว
เนี่ยคูนี้ก็จะหาที่เที่ยวอ่ะทุกคนหาแน่
นอนน้อยในอินเตอร์เน็ตใน Google นะคะแล้ว
ก็แต่ร้านอาหารเนี่ยครูนิคจะหาร้านอาหาร
ใหม่ๆๆ
ใช่ครับใช้คุยอีกแล้วแท็กคือถ้าเคยไปนะคะ
ส่งรถเคยไปแล้วอนุชนิวยอร์กอย่างเงี้ยเคย
ไปแล้วและถ้าจะไปอีกครั้งที่ 2
คุยจะไปหาร้านอาหารเหมือนเดิมเอ้าๆทำไม
รู้สึกอร่อยไงถ้าร้านไหนอร่อยอย่างเงี้ย
อ่ะเราก็อาจจะแบบเออเราจะไปกินนะแต่ก็
เหมือนคนนี้เหมือนกันนะคะเราก็หาร้าน
อาหารใหม่ๆหรือร้านที่มีคนคนบอกใน
อินเตอร์เน็ตว่าออกไปดอกต้องกินร้านนี้ไป
ฝรั่งเศสไปปารีสต้องกินร้านนี้
ใช่คุณอี๊ดจริงๆแล้วคุณนี้ก็ชอบกินอาหาร
ร้านอาหารร้านเดิมนะร้านที่เหมือนกันกับ
ครั้งที่แล้วถ้าคุณมีไปที่ไหนซ้ำ 2 ครั้ง
3 ครั้งแต่แต่คุณนิจะเก็บเอาไว้เป็น
ร้านหลังร้านสุดท้ายว่าถ้าถ้ามันไม่มี
ร้านอาหารใหม่ก็โอเค
ขับเข้าใจเข้าใจน้องชายเพราะว่าแบบเวลา
ที่เราไปเที่ยวใช่ไหมคะเราก็ต้องวางแผน
เอาไว้ก่อนน่ะเพราะว่าถ้าไม่วางแผนไปถึง
ร้านอาหารก็อาจจะเต็มใช่ใช่ครับแต่ดีนะ
ว่าที่อเมริกาครับกับต่างประเทศเนี่ยเขา
โทรจองได้อ๋อ
ไม่จองคิวครับใช่ขับก็โทรจองล่วงหน้าหรือ
จองในอินเตอร์เน็ตได้
แล้วก็จองให้ 1 เดือน 2 เดือนล่วงหน้าได้
ไม่เป็นไรใช่ครับ
มันก็
จ่ายค่ะเพราะว่าถ้าสมมติอย่างคนไทยถ้า
สบายถ้าเรายุโรปหรืออเมริกาเนี่ยเราก็
ต้องแบบคิดมานานแล้วเก็บเงินมานานใช่ไหม
คะแล้วก็มันก็ไกลถ้าไปแล้วก็อยากจะไปกิน
หรือว่าไปดูใช่ไหมที่ที่แบบเหมือนจ่าย
เงินไปเยอะก็อยากจะดูให้เข้ากับเงินที่
จ่ายไปๆครับแล้วจะได้ไม่เสียเวลาด้วยถ้า
เราซื้อตั๋วเครื่องบินจองโรงแรมแล้วอยาก
ไปกินข้าวไปกินร้านอาหารที่เราชอบแต่ลืม
จองไป
เข้าไม่ได้ท่อแต่งก็สิบเวลาใช่หมดมาแล้ว
แบบไม่สนุกไม่สนุกเพราะว่าเราต้องใช้เวลา
ในการเตรียมตัววางแผนใช่ไหมคะซื้ออ่ะซื้อ
ตั๋วเครื่องบินไปที่คุณนี้ผู้ใช่ไหมคะจะ
ซื้อตั๋วเครื่องบิน
จองโรงแรม
อาจจะบางครั้งเราอาจจะต้องจองรถไฟ
นะคะแล้วก็สุดท้ายก็คือเก็บกระเป๋ามาแล้ว
อ่ะอาจจะเตรียมเสื้อผ้าสวยๆเนาะมาถ่ายรูป
แบบอ่อนคนเยอะที่นี่ปิดเนี่ยต้องเช็คก่อน
เราต้องดูต้องเชฟว่าที่ที่เราไปมันไปได้
ไหมปิดหรือเปล่าหรือคนเต็มชายก็ต้องดู
เวลาด้วยว่าเอ่อยกตัวอย่างว่าซื้อตั๋ว
ซื้อตั๋วเข้าซื้อตั๋วไปหอไอเฟลถ้าไป
ฝรั่งเศสแล้วเรามีตั๋วแต่เราไม่ได้ดูเวลา
ว่าว่าตอนไหนคนเยอะตอนไหนคนน้อยมันก็เสีย
เวลาเช้า
มีแต่สายค่ะหรือว่าแบบซื้อตัวแล้วก็เราก็
จ่ายเงินไปแล้วเนอะเราก็อยากเห็นหรือว่า
บางคนเค้าไปเที่ยวกับอยากไปถ่ายรูปสวยๆก็
จะได้แบบรูปภาพสวยๆเนาะก็ต้องเช็คให้ดี
แล้วก็อากาศก็ต้องเช็คได้ฝนตกหรือเปล่า
ตอนนั้นที่เราไป
หนาวแค่ไหนร้อนแค่ไหน
ชายอันนั้นก็ต้องเตรียมเสื้อผ้าดีๆ
ถ้าแบบคือหนาวหรือร้อนถ้าไม่ได้เช็คไม่
ได้เช็คอากาศแล้วไปเจอหนาวไปเจอร้อนก็ยัง
ก็ยังเที่ยวได้นะแต่ถ้าไปเจอแบบฝนตกทุก
วัน
อันนี้ไม่สนุกนะคะไม่สนุกไม่สนุกใช่เพราะ
ว่าคุณนิคนึกออกว่า 2-3 เดือนที่แล้วคืน
นี้ไปเที่ยวต่อไปที่เอ่ออริโซน่า
อริสหัวหน้ามันอากาศร้อนในความคิดคุณนิด
เนาะแล้วคุณนี้ก็ไม่ได้เอาเสื้อกันหนาว
ไม่มีกางเกงขายาวไปบอกกูดีคอยอากาศร้อน
แน่นอนคุณนี้ไปถึงเราก็ขับรถไปบนภูเขา
หิมะตก
ลูกคู่นี้ต้มยังไงอ่ะไม่มีเสื้อกันหนาว
ไม่มีกางเกงขายาวมีแต่กางเกงขาสั้น
กูนิ
เขาเนี่ยกูเขาเนี่ยช้อปปิ้งไม่ได้นะคะ
เพราะว่าไปนี่มันหนาวต้องกางเกงขายาวแต่
กูนี่ไม่มีมีมีแต่ขาสั้น
ใช่คุณนี้ก็คุณนี้ก็ไปแบบนั้นแหละ
เพราะมันทำอะไรก็ได้อ้ะมันไม่มีร้านซัก
ผ้าคุณนี้ก็ไปแล้วก็เดินเดินเดินแต่เดิน
แป๊บเดียวแล้วก็บอกแลนด์คุณอีกว่ากลับโรง
แรมเถอะไม่ไหวแล้วมันหนาวใช่เราหิมะมันตก
เดินแล้วมันลื่นข่าวเพราะว่าบางครั้งหิมะ
น้องหิมะตกแบบหนาวๆมันต้องมีรองเท้าเดิน
บนหิมะด้วยใช่ใช่ครับก็ต้องเตรียมเสื้อ
ผ้าดีๆต้องดูอากาศดีๆต้องเช็คดีๆใช่เป็น
งานจะเป็นแบบคุณนี่ตายค่ะแล้วก็เที่ยวไม่
สนุกแล้วก็เหมือนคนเด็กบอกว่าเสียเวลาใช่
ไหมขับรถไปไกลแล้วก็ไม่ได้เที่ยวแล้วก็
ต้องกลับไปนอนที่โรงแรมเอ้ยเอ้ยแบบเนี้ย
ไม่ดีครับก็ต้องวางมีแผนต้องเตรียมตู้
เตรียมตัวดีๆเวลาดันไปเที่ยวชายเพราะว่า
เราต้องใช้เวลาแล้วก็ใช้เงินที่เราเก็บมา
เพราะฉะนั้นถ้าเราไปเที่ยวก็ต้องไปเที่ยว
ให้สนุกนะคะเค้าแผนดีๆวางแผนดีๆแล้วก็
ชาร์จพลังกลับมาทำงานเบอร์เดิม
แต่ไปเที่ยวไม่ต้องทำงานนะคะไปเที่ยวก็
คือไปเที่ยวไปชาร์จแบตเตอรี่ก่อนครับจะ
ได้เดี๋ยวคิดว่าตอนนี้ครูหญิงกับครูนิค
น่าจะต้องไปชาร์ตแบตเตอรี่แล้ว
ใกล้หมดแล้วกดแล้วนะแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอ
กับนักเรียนใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้านะคะวีดีโอ
หน้าโอเคนายครับได้ข่าวไว้ต่อวิชาเปิดดี
ครับทุกคนสวัสดีกูหญิงครับ